I was about six or seven years old when
I got my scar I was in the playground
and a boy pushed me and I ran after him
chasing him trying to push him back and
ended up tripping and falling over and
cracking my head open and that's how i
got my scar I don't really already tried
to hide them anymore I guess I'd already
feel like there's something to be
ashamed of comes from around my prep
look to the top of my shoulder I reached
up and yanked the handle boiling water
everywhere I don't notice it too much
anymore for years there was quite a
ridge there because it is one line for
three operations I suppose to me my
stars represent my sister info braces
because they're the rest of me you can't
tell people don't tell when they look at
you you're a while but the minute that
they see a scar like oh how do you have
why do you have that when did it come
from my first operation in that area was
an ectopic pregnancy I had a heart
operation then in june nineteen
ninety-one i was taken for a caesarean I
suppose what I suppose it's kind of
obvious I took a knife the third one
saved my life and I was really scared of
the day I'd have to tell a boy of ours
cars I've been diagnosed with pre
cancerous cells in the cervix and I had
complete hysterectomy in the same place
it used to represent how how kind of
where I was because I taking all this
internal pain and difficulties that are
going on and be able to put it in a
context and externalise it and then be
able to deal with it it's made me fairly
confident in the fact that bodies look
different and it's made me much stronger
you know I think just having that
there's been like yeah well whatever
makes me feel lucky to be alive and
sometimes I really proud of them they're
proof of what I've been through and
sometimes I'm like yeah I did that that
was rubbish but I made it free somehow
and Here I am it's as much a part of me
as my nose on my feet or you know it's
kind of normal it's probably the period
of my life that is shaped me more than
any other
I don't forget that I that's a huge part
of me and I think it's important to
reminder of why I've learned from it
everyone obviously has these kind of
small imperfections that have define
another way and this is mine I don't
think there's ever been a time where
I've not been proud of my skull it's my
little story I'm definitely happier in
my skin
you